what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
we have a lot of news to talk about
including some important MCU timelines
and shows and movies that you need to
watch before some upcoming Marvel movies
come out which are confirmed by some
people over at Marvel we're going to
talk about how Marvel right now is
breaking records and doing phenomenally
in the box office and is in fact not
dying as some people would say but in
fact they are doing the opposite and
with the introduction of the X-Men and
mutants coming very very soon things are
only going to get even more exciting and
the big thing that we're going to talk
about today is indeed the mutants but
more specifically an actual mutant movie
so far we've only been teased with the
mutants in the MCU and we do know a
little bit about the X-Men that are
coming in Phase 5 and phase six and we
know that it's going to be sort of a
blend of mutants both old and new and
actual X-Men meaning mutants that are
are actually a part of the literal X-Men
team or the Brotherhood of evil mutants
with Magneto yes there is a lot
happening with the X-Men and mutants and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe the old
universes are colliding with our current
universe and we're about to introduce
new characters in the next Saga there's
a lot happening but we are indeed going
to be getting an official movie that is
going to apparently reboot the mutants
altogether which is kind of what we
expected but does give us a little bit
of clarity on what Marvel studios's
plans are for the mutants so if you love
Marvel and want to stay up to date be
sure to subscribe to the channel you can
also check out our patreon account our
Discord and our website as well we'll
link all of those down below we also
have a giveaway which we'll talk about
at the end so admittingly Marvel Studios
right now is doing a lot with the
Multiverse Saga which is expected when
you start to jump over into other
universes and eventually have universes
Collide into each other and have
characters collide with each other as
well which is what we're going to see
happen in secret Wars Spider-Man no way
home and Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness have already
prepared us for incursions in Spider-Man
no way home we didn't exactly see
universes physically collide with each
other but of course we saw the
characters cross over but in doctor
strange and the Multiverse of Madness we
learned that universes can literally
Collide into each other destroying one
or both of them typically in the comics
that's what secret Wars is really about
incursions happen and basically the
whole Multiverse does get destroyed and
characters do cross over with each other
when these universes Collide that is
what we're about to face in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and with that we know
that the old X-Men from the fox Universe
are going to collide with the MCU and
make their way over to the MCU Deadpool
3 is really going to be the start of
this and then it's going to finish off
in secret Wars unfortunately until then
we aren't really going to see any new
X-Men in the MCU it looks like Kevin
feige and Marvel Studios are saving that
for phase 7. and we've talked about this
a lot and I think the next Saga is
indeed going to be a mutant Saga but
will have to wait and see on that but we
do know they're coming in Phase seven
and in fact we have been told before
that Marvel Studios is planning for an
actual movie titled the mutants this was
reported a little bit ago by the
illuminurdy actually specifically
reported on by my buddy Richard nebbins
and when that report came out a while
ago it stated that right now Marvel
Studios is doing a project about the
mutants and the X-Men that is going to
be led and produced by Kevin feige and
like I mentioned the title for it at
least for right now is indeed called the
mutants and the movie is intended to be
a reboot now of course this makes
perfect sense and it could mean a couple
of things one the reset could simply be
referring to the old Fox X-Men Universe
being completely reset being done that's
over we're not gonna see those X-Men
again but that's pretty much how it was
the old Fox Universe was dead and we
knew it wasn't a part of the MCU and we
know that that Disney now has the rights
to use the X-Men in movies so with the
exception of cases like doctor strange
and the Multiverse of Madness bringing
back Professor X and Deadpool bringing
back Wolverine and some other X-Men as
well and whoever they bring back in
secret Wars that franchise is done it
had a great run and produced some great
X-Men films but new X-Men are coming
which is fantastic but there is
something else that rebooting the
franchise could actually mean and this
kind of comes with an actual film titled
the mutants the reboot could mean that
right now there isn't actually an X-Men
team there could be mutants in the MCU
as we know but not an actual team that
could be where this actual movie The
mutants comes into play this could be a
true origin story of some mutants
getting together to form the X-Men and
in turn the Brotherhood of mutants
that's right we could be looking at a
classic origin story or Charles Xavier
and Max eisenhart who of course would
later go on to change his name to Eric
and then of course go by Magneto now
we've only really seen this on screen
one time X-Men first Class but we do
know that Kevin feige does not really
like to do things that have already been
done before the perfect example of that
is Spider-Man homecoming they did not
show the classic Uncle Ben dying and
Peter Parker getting bit by the
radioactive spider getting his powers
because Kevin feige stated we already
know that happens we've already seen it
before and with a Fantastic Four he said
it's not exactly going to be a true
origin story because again we've already
seen that so as far as Charles and Eric
meeting expect something maybe just a
little bit different and the origin for
the X-Men to possibly be a little bit
different as well now it has been
rumored that Marvel Studios is
considering really diving into the fact
that the normal humans of the world kind
of have a problem with mutants and this
actually kind of lines up with the
sokovia Accords where basically the
world decided that they need to keep
these superheroes in check and they
showed us that not everybody really
thinks of these superheroes so highly
but in fact some people are quite afraid
of them and the destruction that they
could cause like the Hulk so this could
fit quite nicely with The Narrative of
the MCU that we have so far and what's
really interesting about this which is
really exciting is that this project is
seemingly going to combine Classic X-Men
that we know and love like Professor X
Magneto storm Wolverine Cyclops Beast
the well-known characters with
lesser-known mutants and actually put a
Twist on it like Kamala Khan Miss Marvel
they said that she was a mutant and
Kevin feige did say that yeah she's a
mutant which is not how she is in the
comics so expect a pretty good twist
Kevin feige is already starting with it
by making Kamala Khan a mutant when she
wasn't in the comics so whatever Kevin
feige has in store for us in this
mutants movie it is going to be fresh
and something that we haven't seen
before it's sad that we have to wait
till phase seven to probably get this
but we do have a lot going on in the MCU
until then and I'm really glad to hear
that everybody is loving guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. in fact Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 is doing incredible at
the box office right now in fact it has
the best second to weekend hold for any
MCU project post the pandemic so
basically kind of the best since phase
three in fact it's second weekend it
earned 58 million which was better than
the second weekend for both Guardians of
the Galaxy one and two so Marvel fans
are loving this which is great because
Ant-Man on the WASP Quantum Mania had
pretty much the worst fall off in the
second weekend and a lot of people said
that the MCU was dead but no it is not
in Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is
living proof of that so lots of exciting
things coming including secret Invasion
and the Marvels and Samuel L Jackson has
recently opened up and told us what we
need to watch before we watch the
Marvels which coincidentally kind of
gives us a timeline for the marbles
which I know some people have been
wanting to know Samuel L Jackson said in
the latest issue of Empire that you have
to watch One Division before this is of
course so you can learn about Monica
Rambo you have to watch Miss Marvel
before of course to learn about Miss
Marvel kamalakon and he says that you
have to watch secret Invasion first
which means in the timeline the Marvels
does come after secret Invasion which is
something that wasn't made entirely
clear until now but that's coming up
pretty soon we're going to be doing the
watch parties for that so be on the
lookout and of course the Marvels is
right around the corner not too far away
and it honestly does look pretty good so
a lot of exciting things happening for
the MCU in this Saga and the next so let
us know your thoughts about all of this
in the comments down below and how
excited are you going to be for the
mutants let us know please don't forget
to like the video as it really helps the
video don't forget to subscribe and
leave a comment so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for for watching wolf wolf
me